monsieur gorski en américain d'une
soixantaine d'années qui se nourrit
cherche effectivement
allé en personne
ils ont uniquement des mcdo depuis
écoutez bien
1972 et
pour lui ce régime lui va très bien il
mange de bigmat par jour il aurait donc
battu le record vertigineux de plus de
30000 de ses sandwichs à léquilibre
diététique on peut le dire contestable
je suis encore vivant at il dit en
flandre faut-il s'inquiéter de la
variole du singe qui se propage dans le
monde entier alors j'assiste ça ça fait
flipper la baisse affecte l'image que la
variole on est vaccinés mais celle du
sage apparaît a priori pas donc
attention cette variole du singe elle
circule entre les animaux et de temps en
temps on sait qu'il peut avoir une
transmission de l'animal à l'homme au
travers de morsures de blessure de
contact avec des liquides ce qui
inquiète les autorités ce quinqua
notamment le royaume uni le portugal
l'espagne comme vous l'avez dit c'est
qu'on a détecté des transmissions
interhumaines c'est-à-dire d'homme à
homme avec des personnes qui n'ont pas
été contaminés notamment en afrique
depuis début mai l oms alerte sur
plusieurs cas découverts au royaume uni
en espagne au portugal et au canada plus
d'une cinquantaine de cas de variole du
singe à travers le monde ont déjà été
recensés ça peut quand même tué entre 1
à 10% des malades mais quels sont les
symptômes de cette maladie comment se
transmet tel la variole du singe
proviendrait d'afrique de l'ouest et ne
connaîtrez aucun traitement pour le
moment à l'heure où l'épidémie du
coronavirus diminue cette nouvelle
maladie pourrait vite devenir
préoccupante
on a de la fièvre des courbatures des
maux de tête et puis on va voir cette
éruption qui va survenir comme des
espèces de petites pustules qui vont
inquiéter les patients qui vont faire
qu'ils vont consulter et puis une des
particularités de la veille c'est qu'on
a des ganglions des adénopathies c'est à
dire des boules qui vont se former au
niveau du cou raison pour laquelle les
patients sont pris en charge alors pour
l'heure on ne sait pas exactement quel
est le degré de gravité ce serait a
priori moins grave que la variole
classique mais attention on s'est
beaucoup trompé par le passé vous avez
un rapport avec les groupes oui enfin
rapport
tout dépend ce qu'on appelle un rapport
à un rapport en tout bien tout honneur
tout à fait c'est passé une pleine lune
mais en pleine journée une pleine lune
on peut les bienvenus dans paint journée
regardez
[Musique]
[Rires]
à quoi ça sert chabanon ça ça à garer
son vélo
marlène schiappa pourrait
potentiellement devenir animatrice télé
sur ces huit en tout cas tout le monde
en a parlé alors que le remaniement
ministériel est imminent le figaro
révèle qu'elle serait en pourparlers
pour animer sa propre émission sur la
chaîne je ne sais pas précisément qui
sont les noms des personnes qui sont
derrière tel qui est intervenu plusieurs
fois en tant qu'invité dans les émission
de cyril hanouna pourrait même se
retrouver autour de la table en tant que
chroniqueuse comme le révèle le journal
les informations que mme alain chabat
réfute ici la moitié des travailleurs
sont des femmes
[Musique]
rabat y travaillent dans ces champs
depuis l'âge de 10 ans
allez allez il faut qu'on avance plus
vite
dix heures de travail tous les jours de
la semaine sous un soleil de plomb un
jour de congé par mois moi je le dis
toujours campus vacation je dis souvent
aux pages ne pas m'en vanter mais qu'on
me manque parce que ne pas le dire c'est
quelque part qu'on a on mais c'est un
gars c'est le cas alors moi je trouve ça
indécent mais j'en ai pas honte c'est
système qui veut ça ici on critique
j'accepte les critiques mais je le dis
c'est quoi le plus gros salaire mensuel
est fait aux élus jean mane en bas le
passé à touche pas à mon poste à peu
près 15 quinze mille euros par mois à
bruit car même pour 1000 euros bruts
quoi laisser moi que je faisais tous les
tmp tous les jours beaucoup de femmes se
plaignent de maux de ventre vous le
confirmer
quand ça arrive on les emmène à
l'hôpital la balle sont soignés on leur
donne des médicaments ou les au père
puis elle revient de travailler dans les
champs mais quand elles sont à l'hôpital
elles ne rendent leur salaire est ce qu
il est vrai que vous leur conseiller de
se faire enlever l'utérus ah oui c'est
ne l'enlève pas c'est un problème pour
nous elles sont moins productives et si
l on cancer elle ne sert plus à rien et
on va tout casser on va tout casser on
va tout casser
[Musique]
elle est activement recherché pour
royaume uni dans le devon cette mouette
procède toujours de la même manière pour
commettre ses méfaits attendre que la
porte automatique s'ouvre pour aller
chiper de la nourriture en quelques
jours 17 kilos de denrées dérobé 350
euros de préjudice selon les
responsables du magasin les locaux l'ont
surnommé stevens eagle qui veut dire
moins en anglais en référence à l'acteur
steven seagal spécialiste des films
d'action